اهلا بكم الى موجز الي اهم الانباء استشهد
شاب فلسطيني برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
قرب بلده سنجل شمالي رام الله بالضفه
الغربيه وكان المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي اكد ان قوه من الجيش اطلقت
الرصاص على فلسطينيين اثنين رشق مركبات
المستوطنين بالحجاره فقتلت احدهما واصابه
الاخره واعتقلته كما اصيب فلسطينيون اخروا
برصاص الاحتلال خلال مواجهات قرب حاجزي
بيت ايل العسكري شمال مدينه البيره بالضفه
الغربيه
طلب رئيس الحكومه الفلسطينيه محمد شتيه
الولايات المتحده بالتدخلى لوقف القتل
اليومي للفلسطينيين وكان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
بحث مع رئيس الفلسطينيه محمود عباس في
اتصال هاتفي الجهود المشتركه لتحسين ظروف
في حياه الشعب الفلسطيني وتعزيزي امنه
وحريته
تجري اليابان عرضا كبيرا لقوتها البحريه
12 دوله بنحو 30 قطعه بحريه تضم بوارج
وغواصه ومدمرات ابرز الدول المشاركه في
العرض الذي لم ينظم منذ سبع سنوات
الولايات المتحده وكندا والهند واستراليا
وباكستان وياتي العرض وسط التوتر في شبه
الجزيره الكوريه بسبب اطلاق كوريا
الشماليه صواريخ
وكانت الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
اختتمتها تدريبات اطلقت عليها اسم العاصفه
اليقظه واستمرت سته ايام مشاركه فيها نحو
240 طائره عسكريه واثنتان من القاذفات
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه من طراز بي وان بي
جهازي بان الاتحاد الاوروبي عمليات اطلاق
الصواريخ الكوريه الشماليه وقال انها لن
تمنح بيوم بيانج وضع دوله نوويه
قالت اوكرانيا
القوات الروسيه انها اسقطت صاروخين من نوع
هيمارسين
من رئيس الاوكرانيه
بالكذب بشان دعمها لروسيا بطائرات مسيره
وقال انها كذبت حتى عندما اعترفت بانها
قدم تلك الطائرات لروسيا كما حذر المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الاوكرانيه طهرانه من
تبيعات دعمها لموسكو
وكان وزير الخارجيه الايراني
روسيا عددا محدودا من الطائرات المسيره
قبل اشهر من بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا اضف
الوزير ان طهران اذا تاكدت من انا روسيا
استخدمت المسيرات الايرانيه في حرب
اوكرانيا فسيكون لديها رد فعل تجاه هذه
المساله
نفى رئيس الحكومه الباكستانيه شهباز شريف
اي صله له او لوزير داخليته او مسؤولين في
الاستخبارات لمحاوله اغتيال الفاشله لرئيس
الحكومه المقال عمران خان كما رفض الجيش
اتهامات خان ووصفها بالباطله
ختم هذا الموجز شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]